Hello, the internet.
I'm Gav, that's Mo,
and welcome to this
quick and dirty episode
of The Slo Mo Guys.
Due to my occupation,
I often find myself going
through life thinking,
"Ooh, I wonder if that
would look good in slow-mo?"
And thankfully, I can
almost immediately find out,
with this high-speed camera,
and that's exactly what's happened.
Before the world ended, I went swimming,
and I saw that my Apple Watch
had gone into Water Lock mode,
which is where it sort of
disables all the finger inputs
from the screen because the water affects
the capacitive screen and all that.
And to unlock it, you
spin the digital crown,
and it ejects all the
water that's inside it
through the two speaker holes
using the speaker itself,
just sort of fires water
all over your wrist.
And I thought that's
brilliant, that's genius,
I wanna film that in slow-mo.
So why don't we use our probe
lens on our high-speed camera
and see what that looks like?
First things first, I will
have to go for a swim.
Water Lock.
Okay, well that's nice and wet, lovely.
Put that under the light,
let's get the Phantom going.
Oh, I should've done that first.
I'm using the probe lens
because it's macro will
get me really close
to the speaker holes, which are tiny.
The downside is that it's
a maximum aperture of f/14,
which is very dark, so
I need a ton of light.
I figured I'd get a shot of the screen.
This is 40 times slower,
and you can actually see the refresh rate
of the tiny OLED screen
from top to bottom.
This is now 80 times slower,
2000 frames a second.
I was immediately blown away
at how much water actually
came out in this shot.
It's mainly just because
it's macro to your eye.
When you're looking at it in real life,
it doesn't look like that much comes out.
After the initial burst,
it actually looks like a lot
of the water gets trapped.
It's trying to get out,
but then gets sucked back in
by the speaker retreating.
So what it does, it stops,
allowing the water to settle against
the back of the speaker.
Starts again,
which causes another
burst of water to fly up.
It does 10 full cycles of that.
I think due to the sharp
edge of the speaker hole,
followed by the metallic
surface that's curved,
it caused droplets to form
around the speaker holes,
which once big enough would just drip off.
I think if you were wearing
the watch at this point,
it would potentially just get
pulled off onto your wrist.
The surface tension of this droplet causes
the smaller ones inside just
to come out and join this one.
I should point out that the macro lens
is making this look a
lot bigger than it is,
that's actually a very tiny droplet there.
The droplets were also
able to climb upwards,
which I thought was interesting.
Whichever droplet was closest to the lip,
pulled the rest of the
water out in that direction.
And I saw here, as the
droplet was getting bigger,
it was starting to pull droplets back in
that were trying to escape.
See that one almost made it out.
And eventually after the
droplet gets big enough,
the small ones are able to catapult free.
Once most of the water is out,
you can get a much better
look at the speaker surface,
just rattling away back there.
Shooting a whole video in
macro can sometimes cause you
to lose the context and
the scale of your subject,
so this shot is just a reminder
of how minuscule these little
droplets are coming out.
Really had to get right in
there to see the speaker.
Just for a laugh,
I wanted to see if it
would work in reverse.
So I dumped the watch underwater
with air in the speaker,
just to see if it would
fire the bubbles out,
and yes, it did.
You can actually very clearly see
the shock waves from the speaker
because some of the
bubbles that have escaped
are still bobbing up and down
to the same frequency as the speaker.
I actually found that
a lot more interesting
than I thought I would.
To actually get to see the frequency
that the watch uses to eject the water,
and the fact that it then takes a break,
gives it another go after it
waits for the water to settle.
Very interesting way around having a watch
that has a speaker and also
needs to be water resistant.
This is not an ad for Apple.
I should probably say that,
they didn't sponsor this video.
I don't think I've ever seen
Apple sponsor a YouTube video,
it'd be very un-Apple
of them, wouldn't it?
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Make sure you subscribe,
and I'll try and be back pretty
soon with another little,
how this works sort of video,
'cause I do enjoy making them.
I'll see you in the next one.
Water Lock.